hated himself inside to avoid prison
pablo herself was sentenced to nine
months in jail for
insulting the monarchy and glorifying
so-called terrorism
he wants the law that was used to
convict him scrapped
umekulsum has this report
this is the moment police stormed the
catalan university of laida to arrest
pablo hustle
the rap artist had barricaded himself in
to avoid arrest
after being sentenced to nine months in
prison for criticizing
spain's royal family in songs and tweets
as he was led away he remained defined
they will never make us give in despite
the repression
hustle's cases inspired support across
the country
last week dozens of demonstrators
rallied in madrid
demanding his freedom first of all
i think it's a right to to well to
express
your opinion either rapping either
singing either dancing either doing
whatever you want
one showed support with this street art
showing spain's former king juan carlos
erasing hustle's image
it can't be that an artist is jailed for
expressing his ideas
i believe that's something that is
profoundly unfair
more than 200 artists actors and film
directors have also signed a petition
against his jailing costal's case has
led the government to reform what's
known as the gag law
that was intended to prevent the
glorification of terrorism
these verbal excesses that some may have
and which are part of a framework of
cultural expressions
must according to this government be
kept away from any legal sanction
amnesty international says 70 people
were convicted under the law in 2018
and 2019.
the artist says he uses rap as a tool
for transformation
and won't be silenced until the law is
cracked
al jazeera